[تصفيق]
ميسالا خذ واحدة وأريد أن أعود بك
إلى مجد دوري أبطال أوروبا وأنت
ترفع هذا الكأس كيف كان الأمر
رائعًا بصراحة ، أنت تعلم أنه حلم لكل
مدينة ، أن يفوز اللاعب بدوري أبطال
أوروبا ، لذلك هناك شيء رائع وشيء
يفلت منه  يونيو 2019 وانتصار
المصلى وزملائه في ليفربول
بتتويجهم بطلاً لأوروبا
لمجد نادي صلاح تلاه
تحول مخيب للآمال في الأحداث مع
المنتخب المصري في
كأس الأمم الأفريقية هذا العام قبل أشهر فقط من
انطلاق البطولة.
لاستضافة ولكن ميزة العشب على أرضه
لم تساعد الفراعنة الذين فشلوا
في أدوار خروج المغلوب ولم يؤدوا في
المستوى الأعلى بصدق ، لذلك أنا لا
أتحدث فقط أنا أتحدث أنا لا أتحدث
عن اللاعب وأتحدث  أنا نفسي
ولكننا كفريق لم نقدم أداءً جيدًا ولكن
كان هناك الكثير من الضغط على اللاعب
في المنتخب الوطني ، لم يكونوا
سعداء بالكثير من الأشياء.
في
التجربة ، هل يحتاجون إلى
إصلاح شامل ، كما تعتقد في
زميل كرة القدم المصري ، أعني
أنك خضت عددًا من المنافسات
مع الاتحاد ، نعم لدي الكثير أعتقد
أنه كان من الضروري فقط أن نكون صادقين مع
أنفسنا في بعض الأحيان  بالنسبة للمنتخب الوطني
، فإن الاتحاد ألق نظرة على
الحسابات معي ، فأنت تعلم أن
موقعي مختلف قليلاً عن
اللاعبين ، لذا ليس لأنني نجم ولكن
أيضًا لأنه يجعلني أشعر بالراحة
على سبيل المثال دولة أفريقية كان لدينا
كانوا في الفندق وكان الناس يأتون
إلى الفندق بسهولة ،
فهم يجلسون في الطابق السفلي بسهولة ، وهو أمر
غير طبيعي كان لدينا يوم عطلة ولم
أستطع النزول من الغرفة حتى
9:00 9:30 عندما أحاول الذهاب  لقد كان كل شيء
مثل 200 شخص معي وأنا أقول
لماذا تشكو أنا
أشتكي لأنني إنسان أريدك
مع اللاعبين ، هل
فكرت يومًا في الاعتزال من المنتخب الوطني
، من الصعب جدًا أن تعلم أنني أحب
هذا البلد  من قلبي "  كان دائمًا
في ذهني عندما غادرت مصر ، لذلك عندما
كان عمري 19 عامًا ، كان دائمًا في
ذهني شيئًا يدفعني إلى الأمام
للأداء ، أصبح التبول مبدعًا للأطفال
ليكونوا مثل الحلم للأطفال ليكونوا في
يوم من الأيام مثلي  في رأيي أنا أريد أن
أكون ذلك الشخص ، فالتقاعد من
المنتخب الوطني أمر ضخم بالنسبة لي
، فقد طغى الجدل على الأداء الباهت على أرض
الملعب بسبب الجدل الذي
دار في وقت مبكر من البطولة ، حيث أطلق الاتحاد المصري لكرة القدم
أماورا المياه على الفريق
.  بعد ظهور
ادعاءات بالتحرش الجنسي
على الإنترنت ، لكن أعيد اللاعب البالغ من العمر 25 عامًا
إلى منصبه بعد أن بدا أن اللاعبين الرئيسيين بما في ذلك
صلاح يقدمون له الدعم على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ، فلنتحدث عن
الجدل حول الماء في هذا الصيف ،
هل ساعده
تدخلك على العودة إلى الفريق بعد أن كان
تم الإيقاف في البداية بسبب مزاعم
بالتحرش الجنسي ليس على الإطلاق
لأنني لست قائد المنتخب الوطني
أنا لست مدير الفريق لست المدرب
صدقني  أنا أقوم بتغيير دقيق
في الكثير من الأشياء هناك ، لكنني لاعب
ولكن هذا لا يدعمني ، هل يمكننا
إلقاء نظرة على التغريدة وتذكير مشاهدينا
بما قلته أنه يجب معاملة النساء
بأقصى درجات الاحترام ، لا قلت لا يعني لا
هذه الأشياء مقدسة ويجب أن تظل مقدسة
لك لأقول إنني أعتقد أيضًا أن
الكثيرين ممن يرتكبون أخطاء يمكن أن يتغيروا
للأفضل ولا ينبغي إرسالهم
مباشرة إلى المقصلة وهي
أسهل طريقة للخروج نحن بحاجة إلى الإيمان
بالفرص الثانية التي نحتاجها  لتوجيه
وتعليم الابتعاد عن
الجواب ، دعنا نذكر أنفسنا أن
هذه ليست المرة الأولى التي
اتُهم فيها والدي بالتحرش الجنسي ،
ماذا تقول للأشخاص الذين ينتقدون تلك
التغريدة التي نشرتها ويقولون إنك
تؤيد سلوكه؟  قصدت
القول إن هذا حدث قبل أن يحدث التعيس
الآن ، لذا فإن التحرش الجنسي
هو شخص يجب عليه الحصول على علاج
أو تأهيل ، لذلك لا يقتصر الأمر على
التأكد من أنه لن يحدث مرة أخرى ،
لذا دعني أوضح ذلك تمامًا.  "يا ماء
والآخرين الذين ارتكبوا تحرشًا جنسيًا ،
فأنت تستخدم المصطلح بحاجة إلى إعادة تأهيل ، نعم ،
ما أعنيه ليس شخصًا
معينًا ولكن بشكل عام ، نعم ، إنهم
بحاجة إلى إعادة تأهيل وعلاج
لذلك ، لذا عليك فقط التأكد من أنه
لن يحدث  مرة أخرى ، تم
اتهامك بالنفاق عندما تم التصويت لك
كأكثر 100 مرة من حيث التأثير ، وتحدثت
عن الحاجة إلى تغيير المواقف
تجاه المرأة في الشرق الأوسط
ثم تغريدة ، لذا فقط اشرح
موقفك بالنسبة لي إذا لم يكن
موقفي هو  كما أخبرتك ،
هناك من يسيء فهم ما
أقوله ،
لكن في الوقت نفسه ، ما أتحدث
عنه إذا كان على المرأة أن تحصل عليها
في الشرق الأوسط ، يمكنك القول إنك واحدة من أشهر عارف في الشرق الأوسط ،
إن لم تكن
العالم اليوم كيف تستخدم
هذه المنصة لتعزيز التغيير أولاً وقبل
كل شيء علينا أن نقبل أن هناك
مشكلة وأنا أعلم أنه من الصعب
جدًا قبول ذلك ولكن المشكلة بنسبة 100٪
عميقة وحتى عميقة جدًا
والشيء الثاني في رأيي هو المرأة التي
لها الحق في التحدث عن أي شيء
لا تحبه. أتحدث عن
نفسي ، أريد عندما
تواجه ابنتي مشكلة ، يجب أن تشعر بالدعم
لكي أتحدث معي.  حول
المشكلة أهم شيء هو
الخوف الذي تخافه الزوجة
من زوجها من والدك ،
وهذه هي النقطة الأساسية في اعتقادي ،
لذا فإن الخوف ليس صحيًا لأي شخص ، لذلك
علينا أن نصلح أن
مامي شخصيًا هل غيرت
مواقفك تجاه المرأة.  نظرًا لأنك
كبرت ، ابتعدت عن مصر
وأصبحت ناجحة في أوروبا ، أعتقد نعم
تغيرت كثيرًا من الشخص
الذي أتحدث عنه مثل
الحجم الذي تخيفه الأسرة منه ومن
الزوجة أو الابنة أو أيًا كان
الشخص.  الحديث الآن كما لو كان يقاتل من
أجل مرة أخرى هو الموضوع لأنه يرى
أنه مخطئ نعم بالطبع قبل أن
لا أنجب ابنتي لأنني كنت
أعتقد أن القطع المكافئة تبدأ في التغيير مثل
تسع سنوات حصلت عليها منذ 10 سنوات
لا لا ماذا  r ولكن بالنسبة لذلك الشخص الآن
يقاتل مرة أخرى هو الموضوع لأنني
أستطيع أن أقول أنه خطأ للغاية